you don't have to stay long at a
demonstration in russia before you might
be arrested
police wasting no time in taking these
protesters away
they had been warned in the current
circumstances
the risk of the protest organizers and
active participants provocations is
increasing
and their aim is to violate civil order
in this situation
your personal safety can be under threat
we strongly recommend you to warn your
underage children
other relatives and acquaintances from
participating in the unauthorized events
but alexis navalny supporters braved the
sub-zero temperatures to have their say
these ones pushed out by police found
themselves onto frozen waters in
vladivostok
what i'm seeing now is some kind of
inadequate reaction people were coming
out peacefully
they were not doing anything illegal now
there is intimidation
but as you can see no one is afraid the
city square is completely blocked off by
police but there is someone there from
the protesters
and there are arrests there aren't many
people this time but police and special
forces had prepared in advance and
blocked the square
the kremlin seems to have been rattled
by this latest wave of protests
[Music]
and have adopted a zero tolerance
approach
even putting pressure on online
platforms to shut down any talk of
demonstrations
navalny says his poisoning in august
last year was state sanctioned
something the kremlin has denied the
opposition leader and critic of
president vladimir putin spent months in
germany recovering
this movement is more than just support
for navalny
it's been a mobilizing call for those
frustrated with everything
from the economy to long-standing claims
of corruption
navalny supporters have used social
media to spread his views
and to organize protests there have been
thousands of arrests across russia
and with just days to go before navalny
appears in court to face charges of
parole violations
the kremlin is keen to shut down and
discredit him
and his supporters assad beg al-jazeera
hey let's get the very latest situation
in moscow right now alexandre gough is
standing by for us there and alexandria
understand the situation
is calming down a little bit as some
protesters going home but there have
been thousands of arrests
well yes indeed here in moscow
the organizers announced that that is it
for today that they made their point by
managing to reach
the detention center where navalny has
been held but that
didn't come easy today first of all the
original point where the protesters were
supposed to gather
was completely sealed off the whole
center of moscow the heart of moscow was
sealed off
with buses not running metro not
stopping so they started gathering at
the reserve points and these points
were changing uh in an hour because
every time they would start gathering
coming out
on the streets then police would
immediately detain people
finally they managed to gather at this
spot this is a so-called square of the
railway stations there was a significant
group of people
several thousand people and they had
their protest work they managed to come
to this detention center and on the way
police was
chasing after them together with their
detention vans the petty vans and kept
on filling them
in now there is almost no protesters
left
here but still police is patrolling in
their anti-riot gear
and detaining the remaining ones
so this is still going on and will be
going on
uh for some time we have reports that
they're also
going into small alleys uh in the
vicinity and trying to detain people
that they think uh participated in this
protest or the people that
uh indeed are uh were chanting uh
against putting like uh down with the
tsar and
putin go away and russia will be free
or alexander mentality godfather in
moscow